à force de faire de la télé elle a cru
qu'elle était sexy réseaux sociaux l'ont
ramené à la raison
meriane pas l'emballer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais alors que vous ai jamais fait mais
pas dont la semaine prochaine ma chérie
à temps sur les réseaux sociaux et riams
et qu'est ce que t'en sais tu as trois
followers sur twitter voir on va trouver
un mec elle va trouver un réseau social
et puis on verra
[Applaudissements]
c'est yann des formés au club on se
calme gentil je reviens comme elle n'a
pas pu être avec benjamin papa pour la
saint valentin je m'en suis chargé pour
elle ça s'est très bien passé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai passé une sale week-end ça vous
savez qu'on va mettre les pieds dans le
plat tout de suite ça sera fait aux
mauvaises aux rumeurs qui sont sortis
dernièrement voilà sur vous et benjamins
voilà ça va bien l'asam à nantes ans a
pas été la meilleure
je vous rassure pour moi non plus comme
ça on ira dîner ensemble de données chez
moi je veux bien qu'on devine ensemble
bah je pense qu'elle n'a plus que ça à
faire et là d'un gros bisous moscou
voilà la roue va tourner et 2019 dont va
devenir un petit peu sympathique pour
nous elle en revanche est très heureuse
elle a passé la soirée à soirée la saint
valentin avec la personne qu'elle aime
le plus au monde elle même